winter has arrived at West Suffolk
hospital and with it
come patients like Gordon he's 84 and he
woke feeling washed out and breathless
he rang his GP and she told him to call
an ambulance
Gordon is a typical patient this
hospital serves the second-oldest
population in the country and in winter
they're vulnerable
one in five people in Suffolk is over 65
and in a few years it will be one in a
fall putting it on the front line of a
demographic shift that threatens to
overwhelm the NHS so he's exactly our
bread and butter but we're a district
General Hospital looking after a
catchment population that is half full
of people like him
how would you put ahead of winter
nervous I can't believe there's anybody
working in the NHS
it wasn't nervous about winter we are
prepared we are as well prepared as
we've ever been West Suffolk is among
England's better performing hospitals
it's rated outstanding and gets closer
than most to hitting its targets even
here winter is a struggle and they can
never be quite sure what will come
through the door I'm going to ask you
what brings me here today missus none
but I can see stress in a fish out and
pulled it out of the fish so you were
cleaning the fish for work or for tea
okay I was doing a carpet ops and the
noise just slipped and went straight
through the top we're fruit about Hagen
how much does it hurt it's not too bad
to be fair I was more worried about them
if we went for the nose to chop it off
but movable so I'm hoping to keep it
chief executive Steve Dunn and his team
have been planning for this winter since
before the last one ended the main
change for this year and
you acute assessment unit designed to
ease pressure on the emergency
department we have predicted quite a
significant increase in attendances and
admissions we've tried to anticipate
that by bringing in additional capacity
though if we can't staff that additional
capacity safely we will not open that
and that will place a challenge upon us
and we will have to cope by the end of
the day that brought more accidents than
emergencies the planning appears to have
paid off next morning brings a change of
pace we joined the early shift with East
of England ambulance service which
covers six counties and almost six
million people many of whom end up the
West Suffolk Allen is a classic winter
case he's in his 70s and short of breath
the crew give him oxygen and bring him
in it's our second morning at West
Suffolk Hospital it's just past 9:30 and
already one two three four five
ambulances I can hear another one on the
way it gives you an idea of the fact no
matter how hard this hospital works and
the ambulance crews the pressure and the
demand just keeps on coming
Allen arrives into an emergency
department that is busy and close to
capacity and we're crucially almost 60
percent of patients are having to be
admitted so we've had send to patients
so far today fairly busy at this time of
day and we've got 31 in the department
at the moment so we're actually full as
a department in sake of cool space at
the moments of what it's all about the
Romans trying to clear sight that brings
pressure to find beds on wards and to
only admit those who have to stay
overnight how are you feeling Alan Alan
is going to be among them the NHS is a
source of huge reassurance vital it's a
system that we've got that nobody else
has got we should look after at this
time of year no days like the last in
the NHS but from here on in everyone
will be a challenge
Paul Kelso Sky News a West Suffolk
hospital